I really am not liking the direction
that this shoot is taken
[Music]
[Music]
what is that so it's a ball that's we
had a chocolate like a shell of
chocolate and then my back so it's like
that ball is right at the chocolate and
then you like put berries and ice cream
like brownies inside of it and then you
pour like this hot chocolate ganache
over it and theoretically it crumbles
and melts and it reveals everything
that's beautiful inside and testing a
couple different chocolate today this
one's like a dark chocolate so you got
here it looks like it's good all right
[Music]
this just gonna roll yeah let's go put
these in the freezer the first time I
saw the matte chocolate ball I almost
wanted to cry I was like oh my god this
is one of the most beautiful things I've
ever seen in my life I'm gonna
definitely propose using this into it
and I'll hide a ring in the middle or
some things it'll be one of the coolest
proposals in the world all right
this is the dark chocolate one right
come on not opening Jesus is tough okay
can't help it
yike looks like all the chocolate
collected this giant like
giant like block Chun there's like that
thick on the chocolate I'm not even sure
if it'll work with dark chocolate
because it's so thin I'm trying to like
take it out like yeah it's like leather
it'll just collapsed heavily like milk
chocolate a white chocolate but
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
let's do the milk chocolate one no damn
it
Oh working so we're at the bottom and
crack then this would be a success not a
perfectionist but things should look
good no matter what so I know but not
really focus on what really matters how
do we not have spoons where the hell are
our spoons anybody can find a spoon they
get eat chocolate ball that's all I'm
saying food can be unpredictable so
right now my head I'm just like sort of
brainstorming what is the best angle to
make sure the light shines off of the
chocolate and the ball makes it look
really really pretty it's so sexy look
at that alright so we got the close-up
oh oh my back hurts a little bit like
standing up like that are like leaning
over and like craning over these
close-up shots can you put a little bit
up until sometimes I do go in the corner
and like take a nap not true but kind of
[Music]
video comes first camera always
[Music]
this is freezing for about 30 minutes
please open please don't crack you can
eat it here if you want it here Run 2 is
actually my last ball so this is like
the moment of truth are you nervous I'm
very nervous this isn't work it's kind
of over I have to go back to the drawing
board again so what's the best way to
shoot this yes all right now I have to
go take the other half out
[Music]
oh there is my boy a big ball of
happiness oh come to Daddy
I didn't say that
[Music]
I'm very stressed this is helping a
little bit the ball is set the past is
written the ink is dry stressed I've
been in a long time this is the most
stressed I've been in a long time
redefining shot of the entire video
right here we go
[Music]
okay
alright alright ok that's pretty good
alright you how do you feel about I feel
pretty good I have to do a bite shot
first but he was where is this bull
what's with this appeasing this is a
game of spoons guys when I got the
spoons
I'm not left-handed do I trust my
left-handed because I don't know if I do
I don't trust my left I guess I got a
ragout of switch sides
[Music]
alright we are done let's see how long
it takes for people to like this I would
say 99% of my friends at the office are
my friends because I've given them food
at some point this dudes probably about
it's working all according to plan
where's my concealer you know hands
gotta look smooth and perfect and
pristine for camera like they always do
[Music]
you
[Music]